hey everybody just a quick note before
we get started there is some adult
content in this episode so if you have
little kids in the car you put the
earmuffs on them or get them out of the
car whatever you need to do yes if you
want to listen to this episode if you're
offended by curse words adult language
etc just turn it off now
yeah go ahead and turn it off or save it
for later also by the way we're coming
to a bunch of cities with some tour
stops if you go to the minimalists comm
slash tour we're starting with Boston
and then we'll be heading to other
cities relatively soon you can check
that out there all right here is the
episode dealing with critics enjoy enjoy
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bear that
you'll be fine without me hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua fields Milburn and I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 55 of the
minimalist podcast today we're going to
talk about critics yeah your critics
this episode of Linux it's also for for
creators though because so we had a
documentary come out you Ryan you and I
have created a lot of stuff a lot over
the last six years when I say stuff a
lot of creation it's not physical stuff
necessarily although that's fine too if
you're a creator sometimes you create
physical things but you and I have
created a lot we've written a lot we
have three books that are out there we
put out a documentary last year in 2016
went out in theaters of 400 plus
theaters over the summer we did a tour
with that we've also created a lot of
live speaking gigs with our TEDx talks
but then Ryan our documentary it came
out on Netflix on December 15th in
several countries and I tell you man it
is the best we've gotten the best
response out of everything we've created
the most positive heartwarming response
from people don't even know to do with
all these positive responses I don't do
with all these virtual hugs right and
we've just had so many people who have
have really embraced this documentary
this message we've had millions if not
tens of millions of people at this point
who have seen the documentary on Netflix
and the vast majority of the the
feedback has been positive Ryan would
you agree that it's well over ninety
ninety nine percent positive I mean it's
we this I've never received any I've
never seen this much positive feedback
in my life from anything we've ever done
yeah the the distance second would be
everything that remains right we wrote
this book called everything remains it
was a memoir about five years of our
lives transitioning from hoarders to
minimalist basically suit entire
corporate guys to be in minimalist
we got a lot of positive feedback on
that but the positive feedback has been
an overwhelming tidal wave on this but
of course Ryan with that overwhelming
tidal wave of positive feedback what do
you get you get the criticism you get
the critics who come out of the
Woodworks and and today we're gonna talk
about that because I've had a lot of
people say well how do you deal with
this much criticism that you're getting
how can you possibly deal with your
being out there in the public how do you
create something knowing that it's going
to be criticized and what most of you
don't know is that Ryan is an absolute
Picasso of dealing with criticism I mean
he has the best responses of anyone that
I've ever met when it comes to
responding to critical in and so this
message or that this podcast may be for
the critics but it's more for people who
create for people who who want to embark
on creative endeavors knowing full well
that you're going to be criticized so
Ryan I put together a selection here of
mean tweets from some people who have
seen the the documentary and I'm gonna
read some of these and so I put them in
several different categories and and so
I'll read like so the first category for
example is insults we just had so that's
this is the easiest one to start to deal
with first
I'll read there's four different tweets
here that are insults from different
people and once I read these four then
I'll let you respond you can use your
jujitsu response that you that you use
to really show the critics what's up
right and so here's the the first set of
mean tweets these are the insults that
we received about the documentary okay
first one Ryan I love the scene in your
shitty documentary where you were
reading your journal in the desert all
right so that's the no response yet
because I know I know you'll tear this
person apart with your response but the
next one is seems very quote minimalist
to go to a location on a plane and do a
reading of some [ __ ]
next one is alright alright next one is
at the minimalists y'all are the
creepiest white people alright next one
is I gotta give it to hashtag minimalism
film no other film will make you cringe
more a monument to being a complete and
utter privileged cook I had to look that
one up apparently it's a cuck as a
person who likes to watch their wife
have sex with other people so I've got
the perfect response for these guys
alright so so alright Ryan here we go to
these people were in except figured it
was easy to respond to the insults first
then we'll get to the the more stark
criticism how would you respond to the
people who are insulting us I keep those
crickets in my pocket yeah I think
that's the perfect response well let's
move forward now so we already dealt
with the insults now and now we're gonna
talk about here are some tweets about
privilege this documentary being about
privilege right okay
so here's the first tweet this film is
about yuppies jumping from one extreme
keeping up with the Joneses to another
extreme minimalism it's not good alright
next one is at the minimalist probably
had a ton of money stacked away when
they downsize the next one is watching a
documentary on Netflix called minimalism
it's 100% white people under age 40 with
no kids okay alright okay
responds good I know you'll tear them
apart with this alright so most and
here's the next one
most of the people in hashtag minimalism
film come across as groovy white male
youth pastors okay enjoy it sure I think
of her as a groovy white male youth
pastor but anyway uh next one is at the
minimalists have you tried being poor
now see I could respond to that and say
well yes I
I grew up very poor but instead I'm
gonna wait for you to respond right Ryan
next one is this funny
hashtag minimalism film a documentary
about privilege alright so we have all
these people talking about privilege now
I could write I could very easily
respond and say well if you think it's a
hundred percent white people that
probably is going to offend people like
Leo and AJ and and Patrick and the other
people of color or diversity in our film
but I'm not gonna respond with that and
when you could say there's minimalism is
jumping from one extreme to another you
could respond by saying well minimalism
isn't radical it's actually practical or
you could say yes I did grow up very
poor on welfare and food stamps those
could be ways that we could respond to
these people right but instead I know
you prepared the perfect response to to
these mean tweeters Ryan go ahead all
right that is quite the response to the
meet that round of that critics all
right so let's go next criticism about
the hugs in the documentary the hugs and
so here is a mean tweet this one just
says quote I'm a hugger close quote
vomit okay sounds like they need a hug
that's what you could respond what but I
know you've prepared a more detailed
response the next one last one about the
hugs cuz they're all pretty similar here
I which by the way we could respond by
saying that it's probably the best
feedback we've gotten is I'm a hugger
too oh my god like that's that's that's
the way I live I'm introducing hugging
to my family now thank you for that but
we're not gonna respond with that but
the way that we could respond well we'll
get to that in a minute here's the next
mean tweet I'm enjoying hashtag
minimalism film except for when at jfm
and at Ryan Nicodemus hug rape Oh
that person sounds hugga phobic take a
shot for every quote I'm a hugger and
then die yeah okay so let's respond to
this criticism right it seems this seems
about like valid criticism a valid
feedback here how would you respond to
these people all right that seems to me
like the appropriate response let's move
on I have two more categories left Ryan
the next category is about our hair so
here's the criticism about our hair the
first mean tweet is let's get real how
much do these minimalist guys spend on
hair products oh all right all right
and next one I don't know this is
criticism or a compliment I'll let the
people decide here it says you can't be
a minimalist if you get $200 haircuts
and I just like to say thank you by
saying my haircut is a $200 haircut if
it looks $200 well that's amazing thank
you very much okay so Mario he doesn't
awesome job on my hair yeah not Mario
the plumber from the video game no no no
there's a guy to do because my hair yeah
okay well how would you respond to these
these criticisms about our hair Ryan
mm-hmm
let me think here's what I would say all
right we'll take that critic Sal last
category here Ryan
is I just called this one random random
criticism the first one is these
minimalist guys are trying to sell their
books about how to get rid of books yeah
I mean yeah well what I could respond
with there is obviously we always tell
people to minimize our books afterward
you pass them on to someone who would
give value from it but I'll let you
respond I'll I'll save my response I
won't respond I'll let you respond
here's my I saved that my personal
favorite for last this is my favorite
mean tweet of the group this one just
says at the minimalists man [ __ ] y'all
you can't argue with logic I can't
imagine there sit there watching a
documentary in this like house full of
stuff and they think it's some sort of
project like we're somewhere judging
them for and they decide to pick up
their phone or some device and send us a
tweet they just said you know man [ __ ]
y'all
and so random criticism Ryan how would
you respond to random criticism that's a
tough one let me think for a second okay
I got I got something go for it all
right so what I would tell these guys is
uh-huh well there we go that's how we're
gonna respond to critics I also wrote an
essay that I'm gonna put up on the site
I think this is more for creators than
it is for critics I'm gonna read a quick
excerpt from this real quick this one is
just called dear critics judgement is
but a mirror that reflects the
insecurities of the person who's doing
the judging so dear critics as fellow
human beings we love you even amid your
suffering but you can take your
criticism and shove it up your ass dear
you know I wrote this more for the
Creator so so so oh my god so here's the
the creators portion here dear creators
it's best to continue to create even
amid the vitriol it's ok to accept
trusted feedback but ignore criticism
and I'd like to make that distinction I
surround myself with people and ask for
their feedback and ask for them to
challenge me but I'm not going to ask
every person I don't know to challenge
me because then I'm gonna get a million
bits of contradictory feedback when
usually it is often just criticism so
it's ok to accept trusted feedback but
ignore criticism because the criticism
isn't about you anyway it's about the
insecure critic so let it go
suffocate their negativity by not
responding and that's why you hear all
the crickets on this episode the best
way to respond is to just not respond
we all want to get tied up and and it's
so easy to just dive in and say well oh
yeah that's what you think well here's
what I think about you and then like I
asked me know if you like it's like well
you're gonna look like you you're
fueling that fire by doing that yes if
you hang around fools long enough you
will look like a fool yourself so
suffocate their negativity by not
responding or if you must reply then
send your critics a link to this page
and let this short essay speak for you
instead or you could of course do that
with with this podcast of all someone
criticized you and calls you stupid fat
ugly short tall round whatever calls you
a bad writer a mediocre writer cause you
a terrible podcast whatever it may be
you can send them some over here let let
them do let us do the the crickets for
you basically and if our words won't
suffice will let Theodore Roosevelt have
the last word and actually I got this
from one of our listeners called in with
response so we did a criticism episode I
think it was episode 33 a while back
just about criticism in general and we
had someone called in after the fact I
don't remember which episode that this
was on but she called him with this
quote from Teddy Roosevelt so I put it
the bottom of this essay I here's what
Teddy Roosevelt has to say about critics
it is not the critic who counts not the
man who points out how the strong man
stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man who is actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who airs who comes short again
and again because there is no effort
without error and shortcoming but who
does actually strive to do the deeds who
knows great enthusiasms the great
devotions who spends himself in a worthy
calls who at best knows in the end the
triumph of high achievement and who at
the worst if he fails at least fails
while daring greatly so that his place
shall never be
with those cold and timid souls who
neither know victory nor defeat
I think that sums up the insecure critic
perfectly Ryan is these are people who
don't know a victory or defeat and I
know victory because I know defeat hmm
and and you know we failed a lot truth
everything that we've created is not
perfect but my that actually keeps
people from creating if you have this
affinity for perfection then you're not
willing to actually put in the work
instead I want to be willing to look in
the mirror and say this is the absolute
best I could do given the resources I
have and if I fail then so be it I'll
learn from that so that I can succeed in
the future yeah I just can't wait till
what you know those people that gave us
the Detroit criticism I can't wait for
to see their documentary you know it's
funny like I say it and usually the
criticism even if it's good like
professional criticism light like book
critics or or you movie critics those
aren't meant for the creator either but
those are meant for the public too -
then you know assume whether or not it's
worth their time to spend on that
creation right and so yes I will got on
my way now as I talked about a previous
episode of my my new years non
resolution is to resolve to review more
and so I now whenever I finish a book or
finish a movie or go to a restaurant I
will go out on my way that's been sixty
Seconds to rate that place if and only
if I had an outstanding experience now
that could be outstandingly positive
which it usually is or if it's truly
outstanding outstanding for being
negative like someone spat on my my
sandwich or something first I had a
question why they brought me a sandwich
I would never order a sandwich
in the second why would you why would
you spit on the sandwich I didn't order
but I if I have a really bad experience
I'll let other people know that I had a
terrible experience or if I had an
outstanding the experience now if I just
had a three-star experience I'm not
gonna waste my time writing some in
three stars because someone else it may
just be my own opinion that I I didn't
have it wasn't it
wasn't remarkable in any way and if it's
not remarkable then of course I am NOT
going to remark on it and so will like
will I criticize others from time to
time yeah but I'll do so in the interest
of the greater good how can I serve the
greater good and not try to pass a
judgement on other people but realizing
that this may help other people but it
may lead people to a great coffee shop
if we're in the middle of Arkansas and
we're somewhere and I'm gonna review
give the this awesome coffee shop a
five-star review it'll help someone else
passing through because that's how I get
value from things often is I'll read the
well-intentioned reviews the
well-thought-out reviews and that is
feedback in a way and its feedback to a
potential audience as opposed to
criticism which is often just a
reflection of the insecurities of the
person who is is doing that judging yeah
all right you know I
yeah I do welcome criticism I really do
I just ignore like 99.9% of it but but
sometimes like there is because I think
I think ultimately and none of us are
perfect but I think you're good at
discerning what is is well-meaning
feedback versus what is hateful
criticism like all the stuff I read
those are just mean tweets people write
there's nobody wake away from any of
that criticism no I mean y'all are the
creepiest white I mean okay I don't know
what that would you want me to be less
white it should I dress up in blackface
to to appease you no of course not
I'm not going to work in fact I think
the best way to be a successful creator
of something is to during the creation
process not worry about what other
people are going to think about that
creation because that's going to stifle
your creativity constantly worrying
about the critics I just like I just I
just want to quote jay-z here uh-huh see
Brutus I know I'm sorry see Caesar see
Brutus see success is like suicide
suicide it's a suicide
if you succeed prepare to be crucified
and if you're not doing anything
worthwhile then you know it's it's it's
a vanilla life and there's nothing wrong
with that some people are very happy
with that um but yeah I want to a be
myself and if I you know wasn't that
creepy white guy
then I wouldn't I would be someone
different so a I want to be myself and
be like I don't want to have a vanilla
life like I do want to make an impact
and I do want to make people think a
little bit in stir the pot in a
constructive way not not just to be
subversive for the sake of it but uh but
yeah it's it's it's great to hear your
criticism but know if it's right yeah we
really don't give it any worse at all
yeah and and we're not going to respond
you know you're not seeing me getting
into the the Facebook comments trying to
set the record straight and I'll tell
you the criticism that drives me the
most crazy isn't the one where I feel
like oh they have a point or whatever
it's when someone's just wrong when
someone says the people in your
documentary are a hundred percent white
under 40 with no kids that just tells me
you actually didn't even watch the film
right or try try being poor they didn't
they didn't even watch the first 20
minutes of it right all right and and so
so so what what I realize is that that
criticism is not for me no it's for them
and and and it's going to happen it's
inevitable you're going to get judged
and you know you're gonna be successful
I'm not gonna legs if I name names or
even hint to how I'm related to this
person whether it's a close relative or
a distant friend or whatever but someone
on Facebook sent me a message and they
just literally started that they gave me
this critique I'm having a say what the
critique was mmhmm but they gave me this
critique and literally started out with
a critique with I didn't watch your
whatever but and then consider and I'm
like I just responded back hey thanks
for the support
what cuz it was it was such a weird
criticism especially if you haven't seen
the film I just was like alright well
I'm just gonna give a weird response
because I don't I don't know how else to
react to this imagine we give any book
review for a book I haven't read
unbelievable I'm just gonna going here
right at one star because I don't like
the title yeah so yeah so yes at the end
of the day the best response to
mean criticism is to not respond at all
and I think if you if you start there
and you continue to create then you're
going to win at the end of the day
because if you if you if you dive down
to that critics level that's exactly
what they want and if you want your own
box of crickets to put in your pocket
just go to the minimalists dot-com slash
crickets that's not a real thing all
right so uh if you have a comment or a
tip about criticism how you handle it
personally we'd love to hear from you
also if you have a question for the
minimalists either way you can give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and let's see if let's
let's add some voicemails right here
Sean if we have a couple of tips and
tricks from our listeners this would be
a good place to add them in hello Josh
and Brian my name is Mandy bender I am
calling from Lincoln Nebraska I'm
calling today because I have a great
solution for what to do with an old
wedding dress especially if it's kind of
outdated and not likely to be worn again
the hospitals in my area have a
wonderful program that volunteers who
take old wedding dresses and make burial
grounds for infants I think this is a
great way to honor these children and I
know it is something the families
mourning the loss of a child will find
value in hi this is Jesse Hazelwood in
Austin Texas and I was listening to the
podcast and a woman commented about
what's next I've decluttered and now
what's next and I think that I've
experienced some of the anxiety that I
heard in her voice about okay now now
what and I think that I personally still
feel the need to veg out and not work
and but at the same time I will go and
check my email and now that is a joy to
me because I've cleaned it out and the
emails that I'm getting are telling me
that I've got a new podcast or it's my
favorite shopping site I really like
fashion and researching fashion and but
I get to sit down and enjoy that and not
worry about oh this doesn't clean my
house cluttered and I need to get up and
do something and have that
extra layer of anxiety on top and then
also playing my guitar when I'm playing
it I'm not worried about all the things
that I need to do I can actually sit
down and enjoy doing the things that I
want and and finding joy in my life all
right Joe that's it for this episode if
you leave here with one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
you're green you know I bet that you'll
be fine
without every little feeling that you
got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so tear your tea
[Music]
you
[Music]